foreign
let's go to Phillips in Dayton what's up
Phillips
hello how are you I'm excellent how are
you
good good thank you for taking my call
you got him so right now my wife and I
are on baby step two and um we're in the
process of getting out of debt by next
year uh we'll be out of date next year
so we're having a lot more discussion on
uh getting a house once we complete baby
step three well uh right now we just
can't seem to agree on the idea of you
know a credit score and essentially why
it's
um
how it impacts your interest rate and
thus your monthly payment and things
like that so I wanted to call you guys
to get your take on it
um I know obviously what you guys
believe about credit scores but this
seemed to be in disagreement on the
value of building credit scores towards
you know getting a lower interest rate
and whatnot for our home when that comes
yeah I mean it kind of honestly I've
heard all over the map depending on what
whether you go through a credit union
mortgage company all of it what kind of
rate that they give you without a credit
score when they do manual underwriting
some we've heard that it can be a little
bit higher uh some we've heard it's the
same and so it really is going to depend
when you guys pull those numbers when
you get close to it but as you guys are
getting out of debt it's still there's a
um a mental shift there that when you
say I'm not going to live with debt and
you go through baby step two you pay off
all of your debts naturally your credit
score is going to lower so you guys will
be using manual underwriting at some
point because you are not interacting
with debt if that's what you choose to
do
um but let me say this um I
no Sheila had no dad and as a part of my
I rented my home from the University
where I worked yeah and then when I went
and bought a house we ended that for
years we had no problem and so I
I I didn't haven't personally
experienced that right not having been
up against you not having a good
relationship with debt not like yeah
um and it wasn't like I was making a
billion dollars or anything like that
sure sure it was just I I just didn't
run into the problem and so I I know
there are people who sit down with their
mortgage lender and walk away and want
to point at this or point at that thing
if you're in good shape financially and
you've got a good down payment and you
sit down and you're buying a reasonable
house and if you have to go to the
manual underwriting process you have to
but I just I just I went through it
recently it wasn't huge just didn't well
it wasn't the End of Time yeah
uh Phillips have you actually sat down
with a mortgage lender yet
um no we haven't I mean well we we've
talked to one just kind of briefly to
kind of because essentially her credit
technically is better than mine because
right now
um mine was just lower so they just they
told us the difference of what the
manual underwriting process would be you
know and how they would kind of Base it
off of mine because it's technically
lower right now
um it's not yet at that zero point that
you guys talk about yet
dollars yeah Churchill yes okay and so
they said the manual underwriting would
be a little bit higher
well no they didn't say that
um they didn't say like what the the
actual payment would be and that's why I
was calling uh okay
yeah I would sit down and say hey we're
ready to get this process started and
let's
let me put it this way my wife and I
have spent a lot of energy having
hypothetical arguments that once we just
got real numbers to real things it
settled the argument in an embarrassing
way so I would call and get some true
data and say all right let's assume
we're pulling the trigger here what is
this actually going to look like and
what are the dollars and cents yeah and
honestly Phillips where you guys are
you're still getting out of debt you
still want to save up an emergency fund
and you still want to save a down
payment you guys still could be 18 24
however months out and even the FED just
raised the rate last yesterday so I mean
like things are just constantly changing
in that world anyways so um so I yeah I
mean I would if you want to do exactly
what John said I think that's great
don't do what I said do it okay if you
do but but just know life could look a
whole lot different when you're actually
ready to purchase a home so just
remember that
um because again I think we can get
stuck in what today is and it that might
not be the case who who the heck knows
what 24 months in
um in my world the mental health world
the nutrition and exercise space
this sounds like one of those worlds
where people are arguing over macro
percentages like how many grams of
protein how much this and how much that
and they don't exercise right like you
miss the big thing and you start
fighting over these little things the
big thing in Phillips home right now is
let's get out of that yeah like that's
the big that's that's the thing we can
do right now arguing about something
that's 24th or six months it's just it's
just bringing chaos into our home that
is unnecessary at this moment totally
and then and kind of I was gonna make
the point earlier and didn't really
finish it in my head but just this idea
that you know when you guys kind of like
are like oh do we do we kind of keep a
better credit score here kind of still
play the game here just to get the
credit score because we want the hat
like all of that back and forth honestly
it's not worth it like just saying we're
gonna be sticking to one plan we're
gonna focus on this and go all the way
through knowing that we can still get a
house at the end of it
there's just something that that does in
your behavior and in your spirit when
you commit to something versus this like
back and forth back and forth place and
when somebody tells me it's going to
cost you a quarter of a percentage point
if I'm in a financial position where
that prohibits me from buying the house
I shouldn't be buying the house right so
yeah good call go all in man go all in
and save that save that argument or that
frustration or that disagreement in your
home first hey something that matters
um and be something that make when it's
time relevant